that smells really nice you smell that
don't go too close
gotta be sanitary here
[Music]
frank josephine i'm feeling pretty good
after my win last week it was a good pie
last week delicious no he knocked that
out of the park but i can't get too
comfortable because i know you guys got
another tough challenge for me so what
you got for me this week so today we're
tackling a home pizza style that's
blowing up lately i'm talking about cast
iron pizza so cast iron pizza is great i
mean as we all know cast irons are very
heavy they retain a lot of heat and it's
a great way to make a pizza it's
definitely going to be a challenge
but with your skills at home the home
kitchen i think you're up for it so
today you're going up against inga lamb
from buzzfeed inga's not a pizza pro
like you but she's very creative when it
comes to cooking in a home kitchen so
how do you like your odds today nicole
you think you're walking away with it i
never think i'm walking away with it but
i'm gonna surely try go girl inga thank
you so much for being here thank you for
having me i'm so excited
so why cast iron what do you love about
cooking pizza in a cast iron skillet i
mean i think the beauty of cast iron is
like everybody can easily have a cast
iron at home you can make so many things
with cast iron so yeah i think it just
makes everything a lot more accessible
and it gives me this like beautiful
crust
so what are you making today so i am
making a white pie with
caramelized shallots some mushrooms some
bacon what bacon you know like they
always say add bacon to everything to
make it better so that's it i did
okay so what's step one so cast iron is
heating uh first things i'm gonna start
on my sauce okay so this recipe was
inspired by joe padilla i think he kind
of created this white sauce so i'm gonna
go ahead and add my cream here it's just
heavy cream cool happy cream i love
basil so i'm just gonna go ahead and add
in a bunch of them i'm gonna go ahead
and actually grate some garlic in there
as well oh wow because we like garlic in
this house yes we are just gonna go
heavy let's go yes let's go and then
lemon zest so now i just need my
immersion blender this sauce is so good
i have to make sure i get every single
thing you know always no waste no waste
all right so i got my sauce here now
i have my sourdough pizza dough here
what i like to do when i press it out is
just actually go in with my hands like
this okay because you don't want to mess
with the air bubbles too much but like
you don't want to just like roll it out
supposedly what i like doing is actually
building the pizza in the pan okay
gotcha yes you're a pro with this i am
i just like making stuff for myself to
eat that's what i did
now i'm going to go ahead and put my
pizza dough in but you see the bubbles
yes i do slowly comment yes what i do
when i put it on there is i like to
spread a thin layer of the white sauce
we just made
once the sauce is on i'm gonna start
adding in my other toppings i'm all for
it so here i have some caramelized
shallots my balsamic vinegar mushrooms
oh wow there's a lot of flavor going on
yes and candied bacon so that's my
mushrooms on there and you can see i'm
really heavy on the toppings and then
the other thing i add here is the
candied bacon
so the cheese i'm going for is some aged
gruyere listen whenever you're ready to
invite me over i am so game your flavor
profile is so up my alley and then
that's pretty much ready to go into the
oven let's do it
oh it's hot hot and hot okay okay
all right pizza's out of the oven how's
it look looks good right you get that
beautiful color on the outside
oh listen to that all the cast iron it's
like it sizzled it yes
just going to top it off now with a
couple more things i have let's go
this um balsamic vinegar glaze this is
actually fig flavored you pulled out the
big guns yeah i literally i brought this
from home everybody oh my goodness oh my
goodness i'm just going to add a little
bit more grier on the top
yes more cheese please then
more of the sauce oh my god we love it
so now i'm just finishing it off with
some micro greens
all right and that's it that's my pizza
can i get a slime yes ma'am let me slice
this up for you yes cheers cheers
let's go
[Music]
it's delicious
and i think this is phenomenal
i think you put an intense amount of
care and love into this pie
i think you really did put all of your
favorite things and all your favorite
flavors into this pie and it's just
delicious i just like felt like the
pressure get off meals
that's good this is delicious
actually
i'm [ __ ]
i don't know how i'm going to do better
than this flavor profile no but
seriously you're here
on purpose to push me to do the best so
i'm just saying i have my work cut out
for me are you ready to see what i'm
gonna do i am nervous but also very very
looking forward to it
okay inga this is what i'm making for
you today so i'm also making a white pie
but the star of the show
are these zucchini flowers stuffed with
ricotta so i'm just stretching this out
to fit my 12-inch skillet and i'm just
leaving a little bit of a crust
[Music]
okay i dropped my dough into the pan i
got a little sizzle that's exactly what
i want i'm going to put a little bit of
olive oil on the crust oh
i'm going to put a little mozzarella
cheese on here
as the base
and then i'm going to take some fresh
ricotta and just do a little dollops all
right we got some ricotta all right all
right all right i'm gonna add some
soprasada but i'm gonna add it like it's
a red chili flakes because i think it's
gonna in the oven it's gonna shrivel up
so it's like little bites of pork that's
right bites of pork you almost wanted to
crisp up like yeah okay so it's almost
like bacon bits yeah like bacon bits you
said it okay i have some filet
spicy anchovies oh man this is going to
give it so much of that umami flavor yes
oh my gosh we love it we're on the same
page here with flavor i have this
zucchini flour and i'm going to stuff it
with some ricotta
got some honey ricotta in here oh man
it's almost like a little like i want to
say like dumpling but like not listen
you are on point it's like a flower
dumpling yes
i don't even gotta try that flower
dumpling like actually that's amazing
we have that that's looking kind of
pretty it's gorgeous what are you
talking about like kinda pretty and then
what i'm gonna do is just put some chili
oil all over it so it could crisp up in
an oven okay so let's see how this comes
out
[Music]
oh it's looking good
oh yeah she's wearing she's worried for
nothing oh will it come out we're
nothing look at that look at the
bubbling oh boy no it looks really good
but you can smell it right now it smells
amazing oh let me look at the booty
booty's looking nice
i have to say nothing is more satisfying
than when you think of something and it
comes out looking like it both hot as it
tastes
mmm do you like it
i love it it's spicy good thank you i
look like the anchovy and the flour in
one bite and oh my gosh the injury is
such a good idea
i'm ready to lose it's okay
it's worth it please oh she's so good
i'm super proud of what i did today and
yours was also very amazing but now we
have to go to the judges table and we've
got frank and joe and they're going to
tell us which one is the winner so are
you ready i'm not i'm not
i'm not all right we end it here end it
here bye
[Music]
all right frank this is that first pie
what do you think
it's beautiful it looks like there's
some contrast between like some of the
darker stuff on the bottom maybe some
stuff that's caramelized and then like
the fresher green stuff on top you ready
to dig in let's do it it's pretty
[Music]
that packs a nice punch
definitely has a lot of flavor you taste
those caramelized onions i was about to
say the onions and the bacon
really come out i was expecting this to
be a little crunchier what do you think
this crust almost tastes like a bread to
me like a bread you would make at home
almost like a pizza bread i think the
only thing it might not have which is
not really a big deal is a little salt
to it which would have kind of acted the
sweetness from the onions and the bacon
but overall this is a really nice slice
when it comes to pizza for me i i like
it kind of stripped down this has so
much going on and it does work together
but if i was to give a little bit of you
know constructive criticism i would say
maybe lighten off some of the
ingredients maybe a little maybe a
little less a little bit of a drizzle
but it's fantastic all right joe you
ready for the next one i'm ready let's
do it
[Applause]
mama mia this looks delicious beautiful
beautiful pizza that smells really nice
this is what i was expecting from a
cast-iron pizza look at that slice right
there how it like kind of bubbled up a
little bit yeah it has a nice color to
the crust it looks familiar you know the
last one looked like something totally
different
like a pizza i've never seen before this
looks and feels familiar it smells good
too i honestly can't wait to try this
one let's do it
[Music]
this crust
the heat's definitely this is a spicy
slice if you don't like spice this isn't
the slice for you no doubt but
i like that whoever made this they took
a little bit of a risk with putting the
anchovies on putting
the spice on you know ingredients that
maybe not everybody's used to or love
especially anchovies but it goes really
well i think the presentation of course
is fantastic but the spice is a little
overbearing for me it might be a little
too spicy to eat a whole pie mm-hmm
mm-hmm all right well we're gonna have
to figure this one out this is
definitely gonna be a tough one all
right let's start this over and then
we'll bring it back out sounds good to
me
inga nicole both of these are fabulous
pizzas you really brought your a game it
must have been
tough you know putting these two pizzas
together inky and i had a blast it was
great today you know i can't thank you
enough for coming on the show
but we've got to know
which pizza is the winner so we really
had to sit and talk about this one one
of us liked one a little better and then
the other one liked the other one a
little better this pizza here has a ton
of different components to it but when
you taste it the flavors the caramelized
ingredients beneath
mixed with the freshest stuff on top it
really did come together nice if you
look here this is a beautiful pizza
crust it looked more like a traditional
pizza to me on the other hand the
anchovies
the hot peppers
it's not for everybody so we really
debated this if we had a pizzeria which
one would sell more and the answer is
[Music]
the first pizza we had the sourdough
pizza
you won
one
i was saying i was fully prepared to be
like that i the moment i tasted nickels
i was like that's fine i'm good i loved
your pizza nicole i thought it was
delicious
the
spice factor was a little too much where
i couldn't have a second slice
but besides that it was a fantastic
pizza and i couldn't agree with him more
i
am super proud of my pie i'm being
honest yeah it came out way better than
i thought it would i tore her pizza up
too i thought her pizza was very very
fantastic sure okay it's only one thing
to do
i'm not a sore loser
no no no you were fantastic i tore your
pie up thank you guys this means a lot
for pizza i've never been super
confident honestly so this gives me a
lot of motivation well done both of you
thank you amazing
[Music]
you